the indians trying to
build some home field advantage momentum
they're now 16 and 12 on the year here
at progressive field
so crawford's heads second and three
pitches him
seattle's got a chance to maybe put away
some of that bitter taste from
yesterday's defeat
oh that hurt yes it did oh my god that
was direct
[Music]
right off the kneecap you're so used to
it when it's off your ankle or your foot
but when you hit it off your kneecap
that one
that's a different deal yeah it's a
totally different situation for him and
he can't put any pressure on it at all
oh my goodness
most consistent offensive player on the
ball club now he goes down here in the
first inning
can't make this stuff up man well here
you go fastball running inside and
right off the inside of his kneecap yeah
you're right mike that's a huge
difference from
as bad as it hurts on the ankle on the
knee forget about it
oh man freely will pick it up here
swinging and a miss he struck him back
came right back
with that breaking ball well that's what
he did he came up and he saw two curve
balls and that's it
went from 2-1 to now 2-3 first off for
bieber
on the curve ball now kyle seeger
bieber's 1-2
swag and a miss he struck him out to do
and now ty france weak ground ball hit
the third jose ramirez routine
pinning over so shane bieber gives up
the base hit to start the game but
nothing after
jose gadoy two out two on
put in play there you go base hit left
field mariners have a one nothing lead
rbi for gedoi his third
power scores and goes the other way on
the curve ball 83 miles an hour towards
the bottom of the zone advantage of a
hole in the left side of the infield
the mariners on the scoreboard second
hit of the inning third of the game
is jp open up the ball game on the base
hit to left
there you go another base hit that was
not a breaking ball oh there's a break
make it happen long scores
and jp into second
another solid base hit going the other
way
able to stay on the breaking ball
rosario
and left hill he just whips so seattle
with a great
game plan today murders lead the indians
two to nothing third inning
kyle seeger struck out his first time up
oh he jumped on that that's not coming
back
seventh career home run that progressive
field for kyle seeger
ding-dong it's three-nothing mariners
could be the turnaround
home run for him they get him going
because he's been in a slump
and it's good to see him take care of
that breaking ball mike yeah no doubt
about it breaking ball that was in the
middle of the play
427 feet there it is that is beltai in
the middle
bieber knew it outstanding americans
have had his number this year
gotta love seekers grit and he's just
been grinding grinding grinding and
comes up with another big knock right
here good for him home run number 13 rbi
number four
two outs top of the order here's cesar
hernandez
good pitch gilbert has gone through
three scoreless endings giving up a hit
striking out five and the mariners lead
the indians three to nothing two and two
to jake
high fly ball that's going to leave the
ballpark jay frick
fraley has done it again home run for
jake
and emeritus put two more up on the
board and beaver throwing the breaking
ball didn't get the call comes right
back with it again
just above the knees exit velo of 106
420 feet
a couple of long home runs for the
mariners seeger and now fraley
mariners are out to the five run lead
here in the fourth inning
here's jose godoy rbi single
and a walk and a run scored blew it by
with a fastball and shane bieber on his
100th pitch of the afternoon has his
eighth
strikeout and there are two down in the
inning
well there's your fastball 92 gets it by
him
upstairs so bieber gets his second out
second strike out of the inning
he's retired six in a row
right center field j.p crawford takes a
wide turn and holds with a two out
single his third hit
of the day they held him to one for
seven in the first two games but as i
said
in the month of june yeah he's been
tearing it up for seattle and that's
gonna
end the day for shane bieber brian shaw
coming on the pitch for the indians
in relief of shane bieber jack fraley
the hitter here's his pitch
swing and a miss got him with the mid
90s cutter so that'll do it
seattle leads the indians five to
nothing ahmed rosario over two has
struck out grounded out
slowed it down and he bangs it into left
field zimmer around
third he will score easily
the indians are on the board it's 5-1
rosario with another hit with a runner
and scoring position
giving him 19 runs batted in on the year
and that also extends his hitting streak
to seven games
yeah right man in the right spot he
throws in the slider that backs up
look at too high and stayed on the
inside part of the plate and he smokes
it
that's what we call speeding up your bat
when you leave it up and in
the indians are on the board what an
afternoon it has been for logan gilbert
six and two thirds innings at career
high just four hits
one run allowed one walk and six
strikeouts
fine work from logan gilbert two and two
to bowers one out
runners at first and second
bouncing ball through the open left side
seeger's gonna come around
he'll score in the mariners have a 6-1
lead rbi for jake bowers
second as a mariner his second hit today
and the inning continues with runners at
the corners
a little bit of insurance they have the
shift on and he wide open hole on the
left side of the infield
takes advantage of it bowers clapping
his hands together he's got to be
thrilled with that one he's reached base
three times in the game well that's a
huge
insurance run gary for the mariners here
here's shed long junior he's over three
with a walk
brother goes and the ball hit high in
the air
left field rosario
makes the grab and we'll go to the
bottom of the night
six seattle the bases are loaded with
two down
braveman ready the 1-2
it gets away and a run will score
it's 6-2 so a wild pitch once the
indians are run closer
taylor against grievement 3-2
pitch
to left field freely's there breathe
easy folks breathe easy
mariners win it six to two completing
the three time zone
three city ten game roadie at four
and six well logan gilbert was the story
today he really pitched well at a good
fastball topped out at 97 miles an hour
and some big sticks in this one 6-2 the
final from cleveland mariners get the
win